did you know Intel processors brought
personal computers to the home
totally and then Intel made them more
efficient so that you could fit all this
into a laptop tight real tight and then
they help bring Wi-Fi to everybody and
now Intel's best processor ever is here
which helps pcs do things you never
thought possible like time travel Hey
these pants are timeless introducing
Intel's new 6th generation Core
processor it's our best processor ever
there's lots of lessons in energy
efficiency that life is teaching us what
can a humpback whale teach a wind
turbine ones in the water ones in the
air but as it turns out they're both
trying to reduce the amount of what's
called drag along their surfaces
humpback whale does this incredible
spiraling in the water it's like the
size of a school bus and it's doing this
ballet essentially in the water the way
it's able to do that is on the leading
edge of its flipper
it's got scalloped edges they're called
tubercles those structures play with
flow to reduce turbulence quite a bit in
fact when scientists replicated those
two purples and put them on a airplane
wing they found that it reduced drag by
32 percent and they thought why not try
this on a wind turbine putting those two
buckles on the blade of the wind turbine
allows it to reduce drag so much you can
now gather wind in areas that
traditionally seem to have too low a
wind speed these turbines do just fine
to learn more about biomimicry subscribe
to the wired Channel